eOn the next new Rick and Morty
Rick Sanchez you son of a needs
some people for a thing large pose I had
a job that didn't care if you've done
time or whatever's going on with your
confusing hands I'm here hey
truculent you son of a I mean
thanks for doing this guys what's the
job that was it
by the toilet episode is just an
exploration of Rick's isolation starting
with something a lot of people can
relate to which is being a shy pooper
here's a secret pooping places then
somebody had the idea that what if he
goes there and somebody else in there we were off to the races
poop with me Tony with me the thing that I love is showing how lonely Rick
is and then his rejection of friendship
from someone who really is like a good
person you're not going to kill me don't
tell me what to do you know Rick starts
out thinking that Tony's just another
individual he's going to have to kill or
bully to get what he wants and he's
surprised by Tony's fearlessness what it
turns into a story about Rick's capacity
for friendship I have a million cooler
friends than you I'll be seeing you I
think also just the shock of this person
dying it just kind of I think it further
cements Rick as this lonely person who's
never going to get close to anybody you
know it's like why bother there he is
there's our guy long live the big
catch a new episode Sunday at 11:30 only
I'm Adult Swim welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my Rick
and Morty season 4 episode 3 trailer
video there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs I'm doing videos for all the
episodes this season if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're even doing a weekly
merch giveaway so the episode is titled
one crew over the crew coos Morty
obviously a reference to One Flew Over
the Cuckoo's Nest and the Ocean's eleven
montage of Rick putting together a team
for what initially seems like a heist he
might want to pull off in this space
casino with the giant big vault behind
them the official episode descriptions
that they released a while ago are
pretty terrible it just reads a lot of
twists and turns this time bro wear your
helmets most of the characters he
assembles for his team are parodies of
Ocean's eleven characters or science
fiction movie characters like this one
he goes to pick up at the club is a
parody of the Livingston character from
Ocean's Twelve after that first Ocean's
eleven movie this successfully robbed
the casinos in the first movie but
instead of spending all of his money
when they picked up in the second movie
he was failing badly at trying to be a
stand-up comedian in tiny bars and
living with his mother not spending any
of the millions that they had stolen the
second one is a parody of a Lita battle
angel with all the crazy cyborg parts
that separate into a billion different
pieces I'm assuming Rick is supposed to
be the George Clooney character in this
version of Ocean's eleven the truculent
joke is a combination of a couple
different bits and references to
previous episodes of Rick and Morty on
the surface it's a reference to Scott
Caan and Casey Affleck scare occurs from
Ocean's eleven who are running a car
racing track when George Clooney's
character found them it's also Ryan
Ridley doing the voice of a driver and
he's kind of doing a vampire Dracula bit
is that his name is truculence vampire
looking truck but he's also a real
vampire which seems like a violation of
the tiny rig post-credit scene where the
head vampire was really upset because
the PE teacher that was secretly a
vampire it's summer and Morty's school
was using a vampire bit name no more
bits just use a regular name next time
and the person voicing that vampire was
also Ryan Ridley no more of this clever
name when a vampire's betaine
be human they can just call themselves
Alan Jefferson or something like that
they do these weird scene transitions
like they did in Ocean's eleven Morty
has his backpack with him then after
Rick assembles his crew they show up
inside the space casino looking building
all wearing special name tags but the
print is too small and blurry to read
what it actually says but they're
waiting for Rick's orders like they're
building to some epic Ocean's eleven
heist and when they asked what the
actual job is Richards completely throws
the bid away saying that was it and they
just walks away like this is supposed to
be a cold open joke that's not really
connected to the actual plot of the
episode like Rick Lantis mix up when
they totally mislead you in the opening
scene about what the episodes story
actually is and then they follow the
Citadel of Rick's where this is a long
bit from later in the episode and
richest needs this crew for show they do
that every once in a while on Rick and
Morty super elaborate mr. X and throw
away gags that go nowhere
like some of the bits from
interdimensional cable that's just the
writers riffing on jokes that don't
really have anything to do with
something the Rick and Morty are trying
to achieve or steal during an episode or
the Roy game from blitz and chips you
spend all this time in the simulation
doing a complete Ark on Roy's life and
then when they rip the helmet off Morty
is so confused he still isn't quite sure
if he's Roy or if he's Morty and he was
just playing a VR game the way they
animated it and told that story made it
seem like it was a real arc that was
playing out and he was a real person you
also might recognize a bunch of trailer
scenes from the season 4 trailer with
them at a heist convention there was the
Doctor Strange joke with his intelligent
lab coat strangling this guy there were
the scenes of them stealing this
spaceship from the aliens who themselves are stealing bits of this building here
so because of the ocean's 11 themed
title and sequence here the whole
episode might just be parodies of heist
movie tropes with Rick just wanting some
small thing that winds up not being that
big a deal at the end of the day like
when they sent Morty and Aberdolf Lincler on that epic mission to get those
crystals making it seem like they were
critical for some a life-saving
adventure which we then found out we're
just for partying so they could crush up
and snort them and do his little dance
but they did this whole long misdirect
bit about this relationship between a
bird off winkler his death in this huge
moment in trying to atone for something
with Rick turns out nope complete
misdirect speaking of which I know a
bird off link
they're still alive at the end of that
episode people wondering if he'd ever
come back he was such a weird character
I'm not expecting to see him again
though then they took all about Rick
isolating himself in last week's episode
I totally buy all the things they say
about that and Justin talking about how
lonely he is they've done that a couple
times before like at the end of the
unity episode where he almost
successfully ended all the versions of
himself across the multiverse completely
if you never listen to the commentary on
that episode they actually say that what
he's doing here this special fluid was
supposed to sink all the different
versions of himself across the
multiverse so that when this laser
device would have destroyed our c-137
Rick right here it would have also
killed every other single Rick in all of
existence but he's so wasted the joke is
that he passes out and the beam misses
his head the WTF moment there was that
he actually tried to do it they also
kind of follow up on that again the idea
of Rick being super lonely at the end of
season two when he realizes he has to
turn himself in this grim if not
temporary acceptance of his fate it
didn't stick because right after this
you have the events of season 3 episode
1 where he escapes Galactic prison so
even though they do have downer endings
sometimes they're usually really quick
to take that stuff back but I do think
it's funny when Justin talks about how
quick Rick is to reject the idea of true
friendship despite the fact that he's so
lonely the difference with season 4
episode 2 is that they leave on a downer
ending instead of taking it right back
with some sort of post-credit scene more
like the end of episode 1 with Rick and
Morty being all optimistic and excited
for their future adventures there were
also a lot of you that asked about
Rick's wife on my episode 2 video asking
if I thought that this woman next to
Tony and the red fluid sacks was Rick's
wife c-137
Rick's wife in there a couple reasons
why I don't think that it's her number 1
the woman does have blond hair like
Rick's wife but if you look at her eyes
she's got little bugged out alien eyes
meaning that she's probably not human
and as cool as it would be to think that
Beth was secretly part alien I don't
think that Rick's wife was an alien - I
don't think that Dan and Justin would be
so quick to reveal Rick's wife after
spending so many seasons saying that
they never really cared to explain what
happened about her no joke when you go
back and you listen to people asking
them questions about her in previous
seasons typically their answer is we
don't know or we haven't talked about
what happened to Rick's wife or where
she might be if she's alive because we
don't think that answering that question
is interesting so the writers including
Dan and Justin just clearly have no
interest in explaining what really did
happen to her and if they ever did tease
his wife again it would probably be some
other fake-out reference that wouldn't
require them to commit to a story like
they wouldn't want to nail themselves
into a corner on what really happened to
her like during season 3 episode 1 in
that flashback they tell you this big
elaborate story that seems real but the
twist is is that Rick maybe made the
whole thing up Justin has said in the
past and I think he says it on the
commentary that there's always elements
of truth in every lie so aspects of this
backstory might have really happened in
probably the biggest reason why I don't
think this is Rick's wife is because
they just got a 70 episode order a while
ago I don't think they would tip their
hand on something as big as Rick's wife
right away at the beginning of that if
they ever did decide they wanted to show
her again maybe it would be after a
couple years when they run out of other
really interesting ideas but let me know
in the comments what do you actually
think happened to Rick's wife is she
dead or is she just out there somewhere
in the multiverse and if you spotted any
Easter eggs in these trailers that I
didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments I will do
another Rick and Morty bonus video later
this week there's a whole bunch of stuff
coming up every one click here for my
Rick and Morty season 4 episode 2 video
and click here for my Rick and Morty
season 4 episode 1 video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!